all right time to focus on the holidays
if you're getting someone a gift of oreo
one order tomorrow uh holidays are gonna
look a little different than last year
in a good way fewer covert restrictions
in place and in our nation's capital the
washington ballet's dancers can perform
the nutcracker in front of a live
audience once again when the pandemic
shut down performances and in-person
rehearsals last year many ballerinas
found themselves in an unwanted period
of self-reflection vlad duterte caught
up with some of them who told us how
that time in isolation or of isolation
and away from the stage inspired them in
unexpected and new ways
[Music]
live and on full display
nutcracker fans finally had a chance to
watch the washington ballet's principal
ballerina catherine barkman perform as
the sugar plum fairy in person it's not
through zoom it's not through a video
it's live and just the energy of coming
back to this place
was like
stepping into like a cathedral you know
for me
this is where
my heart has wanted to be for the last
two years
and we're here and now i just don't want
to miss a second
because you know what's been lost
because it was gone
and with that loss comes this like
profound appreciation that i just don't
want to miss it again last year we spoke
to bachmann virtually when the pandemic
shuttered stages across the country
bachmann and the entire company were
forced to practice from their living and
dining rooms dancers and delay indelovu
and nardia badou spent quarantine
together i couldn't really wrap my head
around my identity without ballet badou
has been with the company five years i
did have a little bit of a crisis i
didn't know myself outside of performing
all of my decisions were based off of
myself in that identity so it was really
difficult but she turned that struggle
into a search for new inspiration i
discovered that i have talents in other
places like i have a passion for
teaching pilates also i discovered that
maybe i
could
potentially
push myself outside of ballet and
develop my personality i always knew
that whether it's two three years four
years locked down i would still come
back and that's is when i realized oh
now let me put my brain to work on the
other things
indelovu focused on one of his passions
making dance more inclusive by
choreographing new pieces specifically
for dancers of color what's changed and
what needs to be done going further
now women of color
are more in the forefront are more
showcased now what we need to do is
shift perspectives and we need to create
these new stories these new story lines
for teenage dancers amaya joseph and
sasha perkins the pandemic brought
conversations about inclusion and
equality center stage that time was
really difficult i feel like now with
people that are more open
to
to inclusion and things like that i feel
like even people who aren't of color are
able to be a part of these conversations
i did take part in a lot of protests in
the long term definitely it was very
hopeful for me
to see that our country was changing and
that there was something to look forward
to in terms of racial equality and
justice
my intention for going on stage has
shifted in the last year last two years
inspired by what was happening during
the quarantine barkman says she regained
her identity during the pandemic my eyes
were open to so many things
on the stage this year her mission is
simple if i'm really doing this to
spread joy then it shouldn't really
matter if two people are watching if a
full audience is watching if it's not
even live and there's just this
sacredness now
[Music]
i love what catherine told me if you can
go to the super bowl go to the super
bowl it's the same thing with the ballet
if you can go to the ballet go to the
ballet the washington ballet's
nutcracker will run through the day
after christmas and then it's on the
swan lake the ballet the dancers were
performing when the pandemic first hit
this was a remarkable moment for me
because i spoke to catherine during the
pandemic and we talked about
practicing virtually and to see them
back on the stage and to meet the
dancers and to hear that if you've been
doing this for your whole life and all
of a sudden you can't do it yeah what
does that do for you yeah who are you
who are you that was what they
discovered about and there's 16 17. the
the clatter the two that we spoke to
amaya and sasha are 16 and 17 years
they're the next generation and when as
when you see the next generation you
hear from them i'm very hopeful and
optimistic spreading joy i like a lot of
people watching thank you vlad
appreciate it